this is from reuters pentagon stumped by
extremism in the ranks orders stand down
in next
60 days they say the u.s military on
wednesday acknowledged
it was unsure about how to address white
nationalism
and other extremism in its ranks and
announced plans for
military-wide stand downs causing
regular activity at some point
in the next 60 days to tackle the issue
the decision to hold a stand down
was made by lloyd austin who made
history by becoming
the military's first black defense
secretary after a long career rising in
the ranks of the army
in his confirmation hearing austin
underscored the need to rid of the
military of
racists and extremists pentagon
spokesman john kirby said austin ordered
the stand down after a meeting with the
us military branch leaders
who are under pressure to show progress
in combating extremism
after current and former military
service members were found to have
participated in the siege of the u.s
capital on january 6.
the pentagon has yet to define how it
will deal with extremism or offer data
estimating
how many service members hold white
nationalist ideology
it is also not disclosed how many troops
have been disciplined for extremism
quote we don't know how we're going to
be able to get after this in a
meaningful productive tangible way
and that is why we had this meeting
today and that is why he certainly
ordered this stand down
kirby told reporters it was unclear
whether the announcement was meant to
foreshadow any near-term concrete
actions by joe biden's pentagon
or whether the stand down was more of a
symbolic move meant to demonstrate
austin's acknowledgment
of the problem and continued resolve the
first thing i'll say on this segment
if they really know that there's white
nationalism in the military they got to
get rid of it they got to do everything
they can to find these people
and these people in my opinion should
not be should not be serving
look there's a line between being an
adherent to an extremist ideology
and having opinions that won't impact
your job
i think people are allowed to have those
opinions so i'm specifically referring
to those
who are expressing a desire for some
kind of ideological outcome
and seemingly a willingness to be more
loyal to that ideology than this country
however i don't trust these people
that's what worries me
we already saw in dc some dude had a
gadsden flag post on facebook so they
got
they kicked him out of dc they kicked
him off the mission one dude was like
posting about the nra so that was gone
and we know how the left and
establishment democrats define
racism and white nationalism they say
trump is a white nationalist
they say all of trump supporters all of
trump's supporters are racists
it's not true meanwhile kamala harris
literally fundraised for the rioters
that in the george floyd riots
and that resulted in 19 deaths
they literally defend extremists then
they tell you
the other people who oppose it are the
extremists we can see how they're
treating what happened on january 6.
certainly a bad moment
but now they're trying to look at aoc
she came out with this huge
fabricated story she claimed you know
that she was
thought she was going to die when this
cop knocked on her door now it turns out
not only was she not in the capitol
building
but her story took place at 1pm a full
hour and 10 minutes
before anyone breached the capitol
building in the first place
the time she told her story people had
only gotten past the first barricade
so they're lying they are the extremists
and what really worries me is like i
said like i said
if they want to get rid of real
ideological extremists i'm cool with
that
but if what they're really doing is
loyalty testing
and purging the military of anybody who
might support the idea of american
independence and liberty
we got ourselves a very very serious
problem because it extends well beyond
the military
but what we're seeing in dc for instance
permanent barricades barbed wire
they're saying it's going to be
permanent a green zone in dc 5 000
troops
it's an occupation and now they're
getting rid of those disloyal
it sounds like we are headed towards
some truly horrific nightmare
we're living in it man this is a
dystopian dystopian novel yep and this
is also happening on the backdrop of the
fbi
expanding their activities finally being
mobilized and activated like we've never
seen before
on top of elements in the mainstream
media specifically npr
calling for cia counter insurgency
operations and tactics
inside of the united states now when you
look at the history of the cia counter
intelligence insurgency operations what
are they going to do
are they going to start arming
terrorists and bombing weddings in the
united states
i mean are you kidding me uh and again
we have to understand here this is
happening at a time where you know a lot
is going on so there's a lot of room for
concerns
rapid yeah it's rapid man looks like all
the opening moves if you just you know
suffered a coup d'etat this is exactly
out of the hab book it's like you know
get loyalty tests you know purge the
military start investigating your own
people it's not what a free society does
this is what a very unfree
unhealthy society does and you know
everything they were accusing trump of
doing i mean it's it's happening right
before our very eyes it's it's
self-projecting it's either gaslighting
to mask it it's it's it's pretty scary
so you you were mentioning you knew
people in the national guard were
talking about this yeah i mean i i got
messages today about it before i think
it was really like started to trend it
became a topic and i read it i was like
this is insane i mean they're gonna use
this as a cart launch to get rid of
essentially anyone
uh who is just slightly to the right of
maybe ruth
bader ginsburg anyone who doesn't adhere
to everything in the establishment's
orthodoxy
is done and they could they they make up
i mean the nra members
a member of a tpusa organization i mean
you could be part of very mainstream
conservative organizations and they will
use that as a way to label you as you
know a white supremacist
look what they did the rnc right so we
had this digital rnc you know
it wasn't a big crowd you had a couple
black politicians and speakers and the
and the democrats on the left has said
they were tokenizing them and i'm like
yo you complain that the republicans are
too white
and then when they when they bring up
people of color you complain that
they're using people of color it's like
there's literally nothing you can do you
can't win you can't win yeah
it's just they they've set up in such a
way that they are always right they've
covered all the bases
it is very obviously an extremist
authoritarian ideology
some of these progressive youtubers were
defending anti for burning down small
businesses
and then defended 25 000 armed fully
armed with the authority to kill
national guardsmen in washington dc so
how do you defend the destruction of the
working class the businesses
and then the power of the state unless
you are an authoritarian wing nut it's
all about power they don't care and then
every time republicans do this all the
time they always try to bring up the
hypocrisy and the double standards they
don't care they're shameless
they just say the biggest lie over and
over again until it becomes truth and
we've seen a lot of people
buy into it you know the sheeple
whatever you want to call them and you
know
they're just regurgitating what they're
told because it eventually it becomes
you know in an orwellian sense the only
truth these stalin
kind of loyalty tests are going to be
interesting because i know a few people
in the military
and after being in the military a lot of
them are disenfranchised with the
military with
the government whether it's the
government lying to them to get them in
there was a recent video my friend was
showing me uh it was on tick tock and it
was a random national guards member
going up to troops being like hey why'd
you enlist why'd you sign up
and all of them i came and say what they
said family-friendly show here but the
the gist was i'm stupid i don't know
what i'm doing i just wanted to check
and a lot of them don't even get to
check because they get lied to by the
recruiters to get in there
and that's not even talking about the
larger issues of the history of agent
orange depleted uranium
and the us government using its troops
literally like pawns
for psychological chemical weapons
testing and all these other kind of
weird experiments that no one even wants
to talk about so there's a big segment
of the us military
that is disenfranchised and the more
that they're in the system the more
anti-government they become so these
loyalty tests are going to be very
interesting
especially with something like a joe
biden presidency when we're seeing
the representation and response to them
especially online now of course this
isn't a perfect representation but if
you look at the white house youtube
channel
uh the like to dislike ratio is crazy
they haven't shut that down yet well
so here's this is an important comment
because
you know the first reaction for many
leftists is just because right wingers
brigade
you know send all their followers to
down dislike something
doesn't prove its general sentiment and
my response to that because so basically
it's like this
why is it that the white house videos
are all thumbs down well what they say
is
you know 4chan or reddit or patreon or
whatever will tell everyone hey go here
and give it a thumbs down
or they'll post the video then everyone
will go and give it a thumbs down if
that's the case if that's what they
believe what they're saying is the left
has no organizational power
to you know online but i think what the
reality is
those who seek out information who are
you know
who learn through critical thought are
more likely to oppose the orthodoxy
left and right is it doesn't mean
anything right now what they're saying
is
like you know when they say tim pool is
right we actually find it kind of
hilarious that i can have so many left
wing policy opinions
and agree you know very much much more
often with someone on the left on
economic or social issues
and then they call that right wing why
the difference is
critical thinking and challenging the
establishment what left and right is
becoming is pro-establishment versus
anti-establishment
and that's why they go after jimmy dore
that's why they banned a bunch of
progressives why they why they why
youtube kicked out graham elwood
these are progressives who challenged
the establishment so their best
you know vector of attack is you're the
other you're evil right wing is bad
that's that that's what we're gonna you
know that's what we've been seeing
the tribalism you've talked about this
right everyone in their tribes and it
just creates this this dichotomy and
this dynamic that it's like you're
fighting the other and it dehumanizes
them but i think what's interesting
about what's going on with these these
loyalty tests
is that the military has traditionally
been one of the last institutions that
i'm not saying it was you know
completely right wing but it was
certainly
center center right and it's the one
institution they really haven't had a
full
amount of control over and if you really
want to completely take over society
yes you can have the media yes you could
have big tech yes you could have
academia all these other major
institutions but at the end of the day
to really enforce
a lot of their dystopian agenda it needs
to have someone
with a gun and the end of the gun being
pointed at you essentially they don't
have police and they don't have police
and they don't have the military now
they finally have their political power
they have their media power
this is one of the last steps to full
consolidation it's very scary and
they're trying to get the military to
wear high heels
as pointed out when alex jones came off
and we didn't believe him yeah we were
like get out of here yeah crazy
and as this is happening we have to
understand on the backdrop we got
information from the bbc today that came
out in an article highlighting
how the chinese government is trying to
promote education to make
men more masculine in order to prevent
the feminization of
young boys we also have to understand
this is on the backdrop of
many prominent chinese government licked
organizations and institutions
financing a lot of top colleges in the
united states
that make masculinity look bad
so this could be a larger play here this
is obviously speculation but
if you kind of connect the dots here i
think there's an argument to make well
china knows what's happening in the us
they know the demoralization they know
the crumbling
of society it's happening and they're
trying to do everything they can to make
sure their own society is actually well
off so
they're acting in their own nation's
best interests our elites are not that's
the difference between their elites and
our elites i mean
they're repugnant for sure but at least
they have their nation's self-interest
to some degree right
mike pompeo said that we've been
infiltrated by china at every single
level
every state every institution is it
possible that this is a cultural attack
against the us exploiting our weaknesses
free speech is a great thing but it
creates a a
attack vector the right of crazy people
to say crazy things and win once they
have economic power
what better way to take over a country
than have it fight itself right
you know if you were china if you were
another competing country on the world
stage and you wanted to take it over
you know there's a whole bunch of armed
individuals they have a whole bunch of
guns
there's a whole bunch of sovereign
individuals there that are you know
our anti-government don't like authority
will never like us we got to get rid of
what better way than to do everything
that's being done now sorry i cut you
off no
i was cutting you off but thank you uh
no it's the kgb guy yuri besmanov he
said demoralize them i mean you're not
going to beat them in open combat you're
not going to beat them through an
invasion
you demoralize society you make society
hate itself you make society divided and
then it crumbles beneath it i mean it's
better than economics and it's the only
way because
geographically america is in a very
unique position you look at china it's
at a very
geopolitically weak position this is why
they're fighting off
you know to make sure that they have the
island of taiwan this is why they're
building the the
islands in the south china sea this is
why they're fighting the indians in that
territory
because where they are on the world
stage is very bad for any kind of fight
that would happen right the united
states is in an
amazing place very safe and the only way
to really take it down
is to of course make it fight itself i
think it's it's not it's it's not even
just
where the us is it's also the territory
of the us i mean think about if they
tried to come from the western coast
we got the rockies not something easy
they could get equipment over
so there's no real ground invasion
that's never going to happen plus we're
armed to the teeth
right how many guns are in this country
what do we have 4.3 million background
checks
in january a good thing beautiful that
is a lot of guns
we don't know it all those background
checks don't always result in a gun
but a lot of people in this country have
guns so there's that that meme court i
don't know if it's real about a gun
behind every blade of grass
so it's got to be psychological warfare
yeah they'll spend like decades
with this demoralization according to
yuri besmanoff he said they'll do two
three decades
of just demoralization he said that we
were done he said i think what was it
the 80s 90s he was like you guys are
already there
yeah because the universities the
universities g edward griffin
interviewed him
and he's still you know writing books
he's the guy who wrote the creature from
jekyll island he would be a great uh
guest to have on but according to
brookings there's more guns than people
in the united states
beautiful right well of course so uh
that's what they're scared
we're talking about more than like
were foreign about not really joking we
were talking and lamenting
about seth rogen being a really mean
person right so
it's kind of silly and a lot of people
probably think it's meaningless but i
think this is one of the most important
aspects of how we will be crushed by
china
believe it or not i'm going to say in
the upcoming conflict the ongoing
conflict with china
the u.s will be defeated and a good
example of why is seth rogen being a bad
person
seth rogen responded to a guy from
quillet named jonathan k just saying you
are stupid
it was a meaningless post there was no
reason to say it it was just an awful
thing to be
and what this shows is people in this
country
from the smallest angry twitterer to the
wealthiest most famous celebrity
they're just they've become completely
demoralized
there's literally no reason for this i
saw something that really broke my heart
earlier
i don't know if you guys saw the story
carrie elwis uh insulted ted cruz
saying everyone from the cast and crew
you know just finds you it despises you
or whatever and you're a humongous rouse
or something like that
and then ted cruz responded with does
this mean you want your picture back
and it was a picture of carrie elwes as
the dread pirate roberts and princess
bride and it was signed to ted cruz by
carrie ellis
that means at some point carrie met with
ted cruz
and probably shook his hand and said
here's a picture of me or send it to him
and sign it for him that's a sign of
respect
because they knew ted cruz loves the
princess brides a very famous movie from
the 80s
and now we're at a point where the
demoralization is so
within us that kerry elwes who once gave
this gift ted cruz
is smack talking him on twitter for no
reason
why is everyone so awful you know what
it could just be that we are victims of
our own success and we have created
these big social
platforms that have manipulated us and
it's and it's entirely possible that
like yuri basmanov said
the this is the weakness of the united
states and we have been demoralized and
this is
regardless of whether china wants it to
happen i think when you talk about mike
pompeo saying we've been infiltrated at
every level
then it stands to reason that this is
playing exactly into their hands it's
not that everyone's awful it's like if
we're all chilling in a room and one
person comes in and starts screaming it
ruins the room for everyone
you know that's a virus and that's
similar to twitter yeah get these loud
idiots that are
it's a vocal minority but i think it's
not just so outside
it's not it's not it's not it's not the
minority it's everywhere it's every
single person not me
fair no i know i know i know it's the
it's what i would say is it's most
people who are active on twitter
most people like conservatives do it all
the time like luke was making fun of aoc
all day
wow it was a lot of tween memes it was a
lot of videos
and i thought they were hilarious and i
think i know during this situation i
think it's important to laugh
you need to laugh but the problem is
it's always at the expense of other
people
i called aoc a liar who's manipulating
us and she fabricated her story and i
proved on the timeline but
crowder called her a horse face yeah i
don't go far right so the problem is
criticism is okay when people are doing
things that are bad and aoc is one of
the biggest contributors to
demoralization in this country
but i don't like the the the like we
have to get away
from being vicious and nasty because
that's what's weakening us
look luke pointed out this story from
the bbc china promotes education drive
to make boys
more manly it is the opposite of what we
are doing here in this country like you
mentioned
we need to teach people like stoicism
pragmatism
to be strong and resilient and calm and
controlled in their emotions we have to
relearn the classics we have to relearn
everything that they knew
in ancient times i mean i feel like
modernity has shown us that
he's given this arrogance that we're you
know it's we're at the best point in our
our development as a society as as
humans when in reality we've regressed
in many areas yes our technology is
better yes some economic things are
better
but in a lot of ways in an individual
level i mean in terms of people being
more independent people being
more free thinking we've regressed so
far so far well even just
beyond that specifically talking about
what's happening in men
in china they're dealing with a huge
population crisis that is coming to a
head
that's going to lead to a lot of
problems inside of china
and and when you look at it
statistically testosterone and sperm
levels are
down dramatically and they're going down
through
through throughout the last few years in
a way that's absolutely shocking and
should
scare the crap out of everyone uh
particularly
in the west where of course we're seeing
essentially
just the the uh what people are calling
a chemical warfare
against men well if you want to control
a society you don't want a society full
of uh
angry men who are well read who know
their history who know what's going on
you want a society full of uh you know
soy boys essentially who
don't know their history who are just
standing up for themselves they can't
sit up for themselves they don't know
their past they don't know their future
they're just kind of living in the
moment in this consumerist society
those are the easiest people to control
don't have a family no family no roots
nothing they're just driftless
in in mind and body and you know and
those are perfect individuals for
you know big multinational corporations
to profit off of because they're always
going to have a customer exactly when
someone would have a family when someone
would have you know
you know values and important things to
work towards and do their transcendence
they're not going to be
looking for happiness inside of a happy
meal or inside of the next
product that they buy their happiness
they're going to feel content which is
going to make them
a worse off consumer so on many levels
this works
for the benefit of of course the
billionaire class geopolitically for for
other countries
and of course not to the benefit of you
me or anyone else listening right
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you